bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on en direct
le crs du centre de samsung et on va
parler des nouveaux galaxy l'a8 est à
éviter
[Musique]
soc
à
[Musique]
puis la nouveauté pour ces données chez
samsung ils ont sorti de nouveaux
smartphone milieu de gamme qui viennent
remplacer les a5
on connaissait avant le a8 et le à 8
plus est alors que ce smartphone aux
dimensions différentes forcément un
écran un peu plus petit du côté du v8
est un peu plus grand lâche côté du v8
plus mais deux produits qui en tout cas
sont vraiment très sympa de prise en
main qui ont des qualités photos
extraordinaires j'ai pu avoir une
démonstration j'ai vu les clichés
j'ai vu la netteté des objectifs que ce
soit la caméra c'est le fruit que ce
soit la caméra arrière
dans les deux cas c'est vraiment
irréprochable
du côté du à 8 on a un écran 5,7 pouces
un disque du côté du à 8 plus on a un
écran 6 pouces
le ratio 19e est vraiment top on voit
très clairement la différence qu'on a
les produits dans les mains en termes de
lecture forcément les plus ce sera plus
confortable mais fondamentalement on
peut pas dire que les huîtres moules et
moi je trouve qu'il ya vraiment une très
belle qualité sur tout l'écran super
amoled un côté vraiment très brillant
très premium aussi des bords sont
légèrement incurvé sur le côté qui sont
super élégant
vous avez tout ce côté avec un bord en
métal son côté un don légèrement plus
brillants le capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui forcément déplacer ici
donc une meilleure prise en main
mais je suis toujours pas convaincu
parce que je trouve que
prenons comme ça y est on a toujours
tendance à laisser un goût de sang froid
sur la caméra et ça je trouve que c'est
vraiment dommage je leur ai vraiment vu
un peu plus bas je pense qu'ici ça
aurait été la meilleure place là où ils
ont mis le beau malheureusement c'est
comme ça on va pas le changer sinon d'un
point de vue purement esthétique avec le
a8 même dans la main prouve que
fondamentalement c'est un bon modèle
on garde toujours le port jack sur le
côté c'est vrai que il tient bien le
format est bien là le seul regret que
j'ai vraiment sur ce modèle c'est que je
trouve que le bouton on déverrouille est
carrément un digital est un petit peu si
tu veux trop ça c'est juste le point un
peu négatif lorsqu'on va naviguer
lorsqu'on va l'utiliser c'est très
fluide
pareil pour les photos la qualité est
vraiment là à l'avant vous avez une
caméra 16 mégapixels et 10 mégapixels et
est là rien vous avez une 16 mégapixels
doté ouverture c'est vrai que c'est très
lumineuse à l'idée d'ouverture en un
point c'est ce qui fait qu'avec très
pâle lumière vous arrive à faire des
photos qui sont vraiment d'excellente
qualité
là je suis sur le à 8 plus le plus grand
modèle et sur l'a8 ça marche très bien
alors vous avez des modes portrait vous
avez un fou avec un est évoquée il ya
pas mal de choses
c'est vrai que bon c'est un produit qui
est vraiment vraiment bien
une vraie détection des visages et
marche super bien là j'essaye vraiment
il ya rien a dire il ya des stickers
petite option pour acheter des choses un
côté ludique un peu sympa sur nos photos
sur le côté vous voyez ici vous avez les
petits bords noirs pour prouver
effectivement
vous prouvez en bas alors forcément
c'est pas un galaxy s suite ça fait la
différence
on n'est pas non plus sans même budget
mais d'un point de vue purement
qualitatif on peut pas dire que c'est un
mauvais produit c'est vraiment un super
produit
moi je suis bluffé par la qualité des
photos dans le double capteur selphy
juin 8 conduite plus sûre que vraiment
ils font très très bien le job et ça va
dans le bon sens parce qu'on passe plus
de temps à faire des photos en selle
fille comme ça plutôt qu'en prenant de
la nourriture ou des paysages ou en
prenant ses amis ma photo donc ça va
vraiment dans le bon sens rémy 18
devrait vraiment être un bon cru nation
côté batterie on a une 3500 millions
perreur sadr est fondamentalement faire
le job du bluetooth 5.0 une
certification ip68 alors au final qu'est
ce qu'on peut dire sur ces son galaxy à
guily et a8 plus de 7 de ce début
d'année
c'est vraiment très très prometteur la
gamme moyenne gamme chez samsung se
renouvellent les à 5 à 3 faut vraiment
passer de date
maintenant si vous avez un peu de budget
en plus que les tarifs ont vraiment
baissé au cours de l'année s'avère très
très vite et samsung vous avez ces deux
modèles qui jouent conseils ci après
vous avez un peu plus de budget qu.aller
sur le s suite de l'année dernière
de plus attendent sinon le s9 et s9 plus
qu'on ne vais pas tarder à arriver
voilà un petit peu ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui par une première prise en
main sur ces produits
j'essaierai de faire une vidéo test plus
poussé un peu plus tard pour l'instant
voilà un petit peu toutes les infos que
j'ai je serais heureux parce que je
trouve vraiment bien et toi vous en
commentaire que ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous trouvez ces modèles
séduisants est ce que vous pourriez vous
laisser tenter dis moi tout ça on en
parle ensemble
restez connectés abonnez-vous mais c'est
moi des pouces n'oublie pas que vous m
vila technologies
[Musique]